c'erano una volta un uomo gay una donna
del sud due uomini e trovi antichi
jenner che per la città ci chiameremo lo
stronzo la vispa teresa e di manuale
l'autista col cambio manuale fondata
intorno al 590 avanti cristo milano ad
oggi e città dell'avanguardia capitale
mondiale della moda del design del tempo
di merda e dell'omosessualità è un
colosso economico e culturale in
continua evoluzione che sceglie milano
finirà sempre per fare un giro in duomo
o a parco sempione o tra le chiappe di
uno sconosciuto su grind immancabili
anche i prodotti tipici dallo sfogo al
risotto allo zafferano fino al
tradizionale involtino primavera mila
nella new york italiane il luogo in cui
i sogni possono davvero diventare realtà
tranne quello di trovare marito se sei
una ragazza etero signore e signori solo
per voi
milano
mica spacchiamo tutto
[Musica]
sono tipo 2 anni che non vengo sui
navigli apocalypse now non me li
ricordavo così malridotti decadenti
fatiscenti
[Musica]
si sentiva
questo monte va a cagare quando ti cerco
in giro non ti trovo quando non ti
vogliono i guardi
farmacia ci regala un po di natale
essere in me cazzo che faccio l'albero
un albero al contrario l'albero che si
tenda scusa l'albero con la colata con
la colata di palline ma è sempre un
albero invisibile per
chi è ora che bello sta che l'accendo
che l'altra cosa
ma tutto è quasi da zero in questa città
[Musica]
[Applauso]
anni fa stavo qui e stavo cercando un
locale che essere una ragazza scusa dove
questo posto è lei che nell asta qui
siamo in danza grazie al cazzo non ho
mai capito il senso di quella tra
federico due parole sulla darsena la
darsena
e di che facendola mezzo di lo può
spiegare però se il commento non divise
con un finale ragazzi siete poco
credibili in me e questo e milano voi
avete portato a riprendere un basso con
la testa questa è la zona darsena un
pochino più in darsena nei dati
dai fatti la risata
qui siamo in un posto importantissimo di
milano cadorna questo pure il lago che
rappresenta proprio il fatto che questa
sia la capitale della moda attaccare in
mezzo ai fili della luce
questi sono i fili del tram errico mio
falegname con 30 mila lire nuova garelli
enrico eccoci siamo al castello
sforzesco dai quello sforzo e quando lo
guardi il castello ma per che cosa no
scusami qualcosa il castello stiamo un
po esagerando con i dissing a milano ma
questo cartello è una merda
graziani è diventata renzo piano ha
quindi stai dicendo che suo nonno 3.000
euro faceva meglio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
abiterei al cast di miramare perché più
a misura d'uomo qua invece e quando
voglio proposte rotolare l'inerzia sul
tavolo pari mani su una falsa del divano
tu il brodo di share lato e dico che sta
camminando ragazzi ci da milano con
enrico
per nico nuovi di dietro le riprese per
sé lamenta perché riprende un tombino
con questo via salemi mette serenità vi
porto in un posto che se nome mette
ancora più segreta che il mio posto
preferito di milano il parco sempione
giornata pazzesca ma assolutamente tempo
fa cagare è stato addio perché è perché
ci siamo noi questo laghetto sembra una
palude è un po come se fosse villa
borghese ci passi è utile perché ci
passi rica se stavamo vedendo città con
questi qua che tutto il tempo è meglio
villa borghese è meglio il fiume tevere
è meglio il bidone della ma perché noi
ci abbiamo più pieno di merda di loro
così e c'è proprio una dal in merda ve
lo dico subito
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
rivolta e manuale com'è che provi milano
supera comunque a me la città sta
piacendo io e solo vedi stronza meter
paga per dire stronzate como ride fame
mangia qualcosa ora andiamo a farci lo
street food tipico di milano il cinese
una cosa assurda
prova questa oscenità
non diciamo cavolate ne vai non è buono
nè non puoi non puoi dire che buono ne
dici cosa ne pensi come comune parlavate
sembrava una boccata di merda
[Musica]
questo al mango è follia pura
impossibile perché le palline ma
delizioso 4 io solitamente solo due non
è il ghiaccio cioè il ghiaccio ha
toccato gela le mani ma non è caldo è
pericoloso perché
questo blog e quindi pompa si spara
dritto ingoranti di pallina
ma stai facendo una cerbottana al
contrario metteremo a quante morti e ne
avrà mietuto il babel di quasi più una
babol
questi dramma
non ce li ha nessuno e la cosa bella è
conti 87 crik crok e non sai se
rimarranno in pietra stupendi una
signora ci ha spiegato che il cartello
vietato sputare è un cartello vecchio
per chi è venuto
e quasi saliva
che tocca il girasole parte del toro io
non me non c'è più un tallone per tutte
le volte che ci ha girato come quelli
che vanno a buttare le monetine a roma 2
20 volte su girato su quelle partite del
toro o non so di che cos'è che fa
maturati
a milano
ritornerà a milano
da allora che il calcio 10 giratevi
emilia
tutti e tutti riguardo
spesa costa di fatto il giro migliore di
ciro miniero per tutti per t male vista
la magica
sono in giro sciagura nella sua vita
orale atterra un aereo sulla mia vita
[Musica]
cioè noi non ci stiamo fermando da
cracco subiti a 50 euro che sono a pezzi
in tutto questo non so voi io voglio
andare in giro con un risciò che altro
non c'è il natale dove il natale ma mère
del natale perché gare natale solamente
per chi spende itunes band il natale non
è un qualcosa da quale puoi far parte
infatti è proprio un prodotto del
consumismo consumismo buon consumismo
bisognerebbe dire non buon natale
stasera questo ci stanno pure camilleri
ci andava magna cazzo ce ne fotte del
natale voglio magna per l'italia come
bello il ganis combat
stupendo e stupendo questo falegname con
300 è
molto bello il nome gotico tu sai qual è
la peculiarità dell'arte gotica e certo
l'incrocio col divino il diabolico
raccontaci il tuo mutuo non so se vedete
ma al di sopra abbiamo il secondo è
rosone più grande d'europa
secondo solo al irreprensibile e trieste
questo ha ispirato appunto i creativi
della disney
di notre dame sotto la madonnina e
l'abbiamo anche la gran mari che chi
ricorda bene il cartone è un grande
elemento lì dove è morto frollo non so
se riconoscete bene il cargo al che
sporge malissimo raccontare i monumenti
di milano paragonandoli a quelli di
parigi
quanto è sposato perotti
poi state pensando
peccato riempito la merda l'umanità è
sprofondata mente
questa volta ad essere umano sapete come
sono state istinti ciao
volte
ci sono i dinosauri c'è più
e sarai io sapevo che i dinosauri
fossero spinti con il vetro e dopo aver
raccolto il buonumore che sa regalarti
un monologo di 30 minuti sulla fine del
mondo la dannazione eterna e le scoregge
dei dinosauri i nostri viaggiatori si
dirigono a cena consapevoli che oltre a
quello della pancia dovranno colmare il
vuoto che il prete ha lasciato nel loro
cuore ma guardo perdere il briciole fede
in dio che avevo io
però in paranoia questo la nostra corona
notturno ritirato non pensa altro che la
fine di scenario la sta esplodendo tutto
perché il canzone perché scrive questo
canale mettete like non mettetela
intanto stiamo morendo il signore ci sta
punendo incazzato nero se vedi quel
negozio i meteoriti stanno cominciando
[Musica]
in coincidenza che ci stiamo che ci
stiamo sentendo alle lune dopo
l'incontro col prete io non credo
secondo me lei
e il prete
quindi niente la fine del mondo è vicina
giusto la domanda è se riusciamo ad
arrivare a cena o se finisce prima cosa
ne pensi dei di ciò che ci ha detto il
prete
fuggite giochi
devi avere una citata un po più coreana
[Risate]
ma
questo è un curriculum per avere un
marito
batte la novezza quelli data
ombrello ha dentro
di se stessa ma all'improvviso tutto
questo 7 hubble e sono morto troppe
speaking
[Musica]
siamo al ristorante
a lui ha scelto una alice camillo 2
influenzerà molto simpatici e così e chi
ha chiamato per prenotare per di più ad
unità siamo entrambe simpatiche ma io e
marley e comunque il mio canale grazie
prego prego
basta vaticano e assaggeremo un po di
cose del posto per cui come sempre
inizieremo parlando e poi sarà tutto in
vacca guglielmo era convinto del fatto
che le lumache fossero tipiche di milano
che fosse una specialità tipica che tipo
in sicilia si fanno del male non è che
sono chiedere lumaca in sicilia dtt per
murano veniva la frana
[Musica]
si legga
camilla ci spiega che se prendi come
antipasto le tagliatelle di cervo poi
puoi prendere come primo un primo un
primo che i tortelli al conto dei
dettagli anche con società quindi due
primi
annulla le brigate viene attaccata da un
drago per rimanere in forma lo chef ma
sei ballerini terrorizzata
[Musica]
ex
l'oscuro corsa il migliore che da terra
mangiare la carne proprio diversa la
rete ubriaco lercio questo fatto va da
venivo solo quello che fai che riguarda
lì poi c'e la spacciato manco fosse una
promuove la cosa più buona sono stati
tanti amici
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ricorda la principessa leila è finita
questa puntata buonanotte buonanotte
ed è così che questa puntata del flop ma
finisce qui tra commenti inopportuni
racconti sull'inferno è un ennesimo
suicidio culinario di ottimo cibo vino è
pessima compagnia per voi che avete
avuto le palle di resistere fino a
questo punto grazie ragazzi avete
stomaco da vendere adesso però uscite
scopate divertitevi e se vi vanno bene
fa tempo di pubblicità con natal un
cazzo e al prossimo video
[Musica]